hey guys it's Justine and today we are
at the Apple Fitness Plus Studio I
absolutely love this place I did a tour
of it before but today I am here for
something very very special they are
launching kickboxing
[Music]
I'm about to take my first kickboxing
class it's kind of crazy that I've
actually never really taken one before
I'm a huge fan of martial arts but
kickboxing and boxing is something that
I've never really done I mean it's only
appropriate that I would do my first
kickboxing class with apple the first
one I'm gonna do is kickboxing with
Jamie Ray this is a 10 minutes and we've
got some upbeat anthems
[Music]
it's happening
I gotta work on my hook my hook is
subpar
[Music]
oh man
first 10 minute workout
kickboxing check so the thing that I
love so much about this is as a beginner
who's never done this before they made
it super easy so like I was actually
able to follow through all of the moves
I definitely need to work on my hook a
little bit but I love that in that last
minute you got to put all of that
together and do an entire little routine
so this was super cool
Jamie Ray hello hello welcome to the
fitness plus if you haven't ever been
here before I don't know this is my
second time here and it's always just so
amazing to just step into the
environment and just see the energy so
now we're here because you guys have a
kickboxing class yes let's go so tell me
about this and obviously like you're
super into martial arts so for you like
what is your history with martial arts
and how excited are you so my history
martial arts I actually had a career in
musical theater originally and I just
wanted to try something completely
different so I then got into Muay Thai
which is a form of martial art and I
went all over the UK training all over
for a year different gyms and then I
went to the best place to go and train
which was Thailand and I had my first
flight which I won and then that's kind
of where it started I am so excited
forget boxing to come to Fitness Plus
it's something I've been waiting for for
so long because I've definitely been
trying to sneak in some like combat
moves into my hit workouts but now we
finally have it and I'm so excited I
think the thing that I love about
martial arts is people just think that
it's like this fighting which yes it is
but there's so much like work ethic that
goes into these Combat Sports so it's
really great that you're able to bring
that and kind of bring it to the masses
because I have never done kickboxing
before this is my first time today and
it's interesting because as someone who
has never done that but I've done
previous martial arts in this class that
you guys did that I just took it's it's
like a nice introduction like you kind
of lead people into that so is that all
kind of intentional totally like we when
we're doing our workouts we really like
to just show the move and really go
through it slowly first and then once
we've got the move into our body we then
really pick up the pace and really go
for it especially at the end we have
like a one minute final round which is
my favorite because the one minute final
round we pick a track we'll take the
best beat drop and when we take that
beat drop we'll put it into that minute
and you are going all out punch in and
kicking for one minute and it is just so
fun so now do you have like a beginner
kind of section because the one that I
took like it was I mean it was still
beginner but I felt like you know you
gotta know a little bit yeah totally we
have beginner programs which have been
so excited to do as well because it just
means so much to me to that we can bring
kickboxing to beginners as well because
I know how intimidating is it is at
first and we've all been the beginner so
we now have something for everybody who
can just come in and we do teach the
basics and we go really slow and you'll
just feel like you're with us the whole
time and we've got your back yeah I mean
that first like
just kind of ease into it the one thing
that I did notice that I'm not very good
at is is like my little book here
because I can do like all this weird
stuff and then my sister goes they're
gonna make fun of you
no so what's like the proper hook like
what do I got to do yeah with a hook I
always like to say we create create a
nice L shape so you bring your fist just
in line with your chin your elbow comes
up nice and high and you've got an L
shape in front of you and this is your
hook keep your chin down keep your eyes
up big smiles how's this is that good is
that good bring it a little bit further
forward okay uh
come on
so much fun
[Music]
I close my move ring
foreign
[Music]
Fitness Plus trainer I am so excited
about this this is incredible so now
you're going to be teaching the
kickboxing class yes and you have a
pretty wide range of martial arts
backgrounds so do you want to talk a
little bit about that yeah so I actually
started um Muay Thai when I was at
University my background is in sport
competitive to what I used to swim
totally different bit random kind of
like Jamie in theater yeah I just I just
took the whole U-turn and when I got to
University I just wanted to try
something new and I also wanted to learn
how to defend myself I felt like as a
woman that was quite important so I
walked into a Muay Thai gym and just
fell in love with it straight away from
the first session it was very humbling
it was physically challenging it was
mentally challenging and like everyone
around me all the fighters looked
incredible and I was like I want to look
like that from my first session haven't
stopped going back and just I'm totally
obsessed with it and it has been a
massive part of me finding my passion my
purpose in life and my confidence as
well it's done like so much for my
mentor Health as well so I'm just so
excited to bring all of that to the rest
of the world because I think kickboxing
is amazing for me the most important
thing is that people feel welcome in my
workouts I want them to feel like
they're having fun and I always want to
Champion the beginner because we all are
beginners and all we're beginners in
many things and I think it's just
important that we create spaces where
people feel comfortable they feel
encouraged they feel like the workout is
challenging but there is definitely
somewhere that they can you know they
can work with so whenever I'm creating
the workouts I kind of want to make it
authentic some Muay Thai but I also want
to make it a workout that someone can
feel accomplished when they've done it
what are some tips that you can give to
other women who may have never tried
martial arts but might want to try like
what tips can you give to them I just
think really common with an open mind I
think that is just the main thing
because I think a lot of people feel
like oh I'm not a fighter you know I
don't want to fight it's like this is
exactly why we created Apple Fitness
Plus kickboxing workouts because you get
to do kickboxing from the comfort of
your own living room your garage
Wherever You Train and you know we
wanted it to be like that so it was
comfortable for people to do it wherever
they want so I think just come into it
with an open mind I like to say you know
everyone's a fighter we all fight for
different things in life and it's not
because you know you may love kickboxing
and you may also love yoga and they're
quite different things and that's you
know that's totally normal so just have
a really open mind and just take your
time and if it does feel uncomfortable
at first just know that it felt
uncomfortable and difficult for all of
us at first and just be patient you will
get it and practice makes progress as I
always say in my workouts it's great and
I mean obviously with the Apple watch
too I feel like it adds this whole other
level of fun because you're able to sort
of see the workouts on the screen so for
you what was that kind of like coming in
and sort of seeing this whole different
kind of way of working out oh it's
incredible there's nothing like it out
there and I think for me I was just I
was blown away by it and to see all the
work that goes into it behind the scenes
is just incredible and I think it's the
best thing out there obviously I'm
biased but it is incredible
thank you guys so much for watching I am
so excited about kickboxing and if you
guys have done kickboxing before I would
love to hear it so leave me some
comments below and if you do take the
class send me a tweet on Twitter or
leave a comment and let me know how it
went arm up okay we're gonna work on it
[Music]